we're supposed to be doing that that
didn't look that hard
are we not easy
450 a little wobbly 450 guys hold on
we're talking about bench
450 to be tough 450 tough now if i hit
450 i'll start wearing a v-neck like you
got on yeah i got a nice bro don't do
that don't do this
i didn't know they still sold me no they
do dude they do yeah they do dude or is
that an old shirt no it's not an old
shirt it's actually
brand new from lucky brand okay yeah
lucky like the jeans and my girlfriend
as my father calls her kid dynamite
bought it for me okay
oh she was like then you start wearing
v-necks i just got it and i was like
oh cool i guess i'm from jersey shore
for father's day
which by the way to everybody who wish
me a happy father's day i'm sorry i
didn't respond
i agree it's very tough for me guys
because i don't care
i i appreciate it it's just that i don't
want to have to go
you too uh-huh i got some lengthy
no people wanna people want you to
celebrate
at the same level that you celebrate
with your close family members with them
yeah yeah they wanted you to do it at
the same level every time it's similar
to when like
let's say you like you book a show or
something right your agent calls you go
hey man
you booked it and you're like this yes
yeah and you tell your family you're
like oh guess what we did it right
then the next person you see they go hey
man congratulations on that show
and you might go like this oh thanks
yeah then they go yeah then they go
excuse that's all you got yeah
on the same level like i can't celebrate
with everybody just saying right levels
there's levels i don't need to be that
way with you it's like that's like i
said
i'm engaged okay right oh really yes
yeah we knew that so everybody says to
me every
guys are like this guy's like oh really
girls are like
oh my god yeah dude everybody because oh
dude you're a wow engaged i go yeah you
know
and then they're like oh do you really
want to be engaged like hey that's how
dude
hey you ain't gonna be living with me
so it's like you know i don't have to
psych that kind of stuff like you know
well
some people are sentimental like that i
remember
my girlfriend had a brother and they'd
be together and the dad was never really
around he was a guy who had like he's
one of those guys who had 15 kids
and just kind of like yeah and now
they're all around and they
and the one boy just wanted to love his
father i swear to god and he'd go like
this
it happened three times during the
dinner he goes you know guys
i think it's important that we all kind
of acknowledge that our father and
and his father go you know john we get
it
stop this [ __ ] job we get it can we
not have a long speech because the first
one was enough
and then he did it the third time he
goes john you make everything awkward i
felt so bad
and john like this he went and then you
know me i try to save people's feelings
i go
i don't know he goes he goes he just
doesn't get it he's done
some people just feel like they have to
do it they have to say something yeah
you know most people just i didn't grow
up in a family like that like birthdays
you get nothing not a big deal yeah yeah
you don't want
a man though as a man over when you get
over like say 35
yeah what is your birthday right like
nobody cares and even even
i would say like like i would say 31 25
dude
check this out and when you're in a
relationship heaven forbid
i want to do nothing on my birthday
correct okay yeah because when it's your
birthday
it's actually their birthday yeah
because they want to like you know why i
planned a day for us
like what is it my day it's a lot of
work
or throwing a birthday party i'm like i
don't want to be a [ __ ] party i just
want to chill i broke up with a very hot
girl because she
she went like this we were at dinner and
she goes i make a really big deal over
my birthday
they're just like oh no see ya
that's a red flag right there because
you want me to make a big deal that's
aggressive
that's what they're doing they also
don't know how to make birthdays great
some people are really good at like
they release doves and like uh he comes
in in a
shining okay can i give you a little tip
here not that you need it but i'm gonna
give you a little little griffin advice
right here
you just need to know what's important
to them
no matter how big or small yeah you know
no matter how big or small it is
yep i remember a long time i go going on
a date like uh
it was like and this the girl says uh
she missed
playing bingo with her grandma from
their hometown
she just me she said i missed it yes i
missed grandma
but you know what i did on the first
date took her bingo to play bingo
and you dressed up like grandma wow
oh my god
but what i'm saying was like no way
papa's doing bingo you don't have to
like
what should i do this big expensive no
you could just be like maybe she's in
the
[ __ ] elephants and you you know you
got like a little elephant thing in it
yeah
you know what i mean it's just knowing
like well you are saying i think she
liked that you were thoughtful and you
remember you remembered that
my friend's wife freaked out because my
friend
uh took soap that was he took the soap
from under the sink and unwrapped it and
put it in trash
and had fresh bar of soap so she thought
that was incredibly
incredibly thoughtful meanwhile dude ran
out of soap and he's like i just need a
[ __ ] soap
and she was like i can't believe you did
that yeah and she he was like
he was like you know i just wanted to do
something yeah sometimes yes sometimes
it's like my girl wrote me this i won't
give a thursday this
long i hate long text this long text
about how good of a dad i am
that's what i appreciate this love you
she's all that's it
i'm like it's father's day like what do
you what do you want me to respond back
like you gotta give the state of the
union
it's my day like you're supposed to
acknowledge me
i didn't have it
no you are though you make birthdays and
stuff oh for my kids i go
all out man yeah big time i can't or
like my girl's like what do you want i'm
like i don't
i don't really need what do i really
want i want to roll like daytona
you're not gonna buy me that like i'll
work for and i'll get it like the gifts
just give me pictures of my kids and
frame it that's it like you just give me
pictures
that's it that's it yeah but you know
what we're doing though that you're
doing is like you have to
sometimes not receiving a gift is just
as selfish as receiving a gift
or wanting a gift i'm saying what do you
mean like like when you go to some place
and somebody says hey i got this
you go like this you go oh no no it's
okay that's actually selfish yeah yeah
that piss
you know it's like you you need being
gracious and being like i'll take this
is is a very as a form of being like for
sure selfless too for them because
that's why they're doing this
so you know you have to like find
something we have to compromise you know
they want to do [ __ ] for you so you have
to be like all right so what is it that
i i can tolerate that i really want
that'll make them happy yeah
see i have still have regret i still it
hurts me because my ex-wife
she she she goes i got you something
that you're gonna really love
and i was like awesome and i don't pay
attention to my surroundings
and i still feel bad about this
it was for my birthday and she opens the
garage and i go
the car i go where is it and she had
cleaned the garage she [ __ ]
cleaned and organized the whole which by
the way which by the way she took
no no but by the way that's annoying
because you're like um i got this
organized
that [ __ ] goes in the shower i don't
know where my shit's at she moved my
workouts
she my house like this and i was like
and i was like but i was looking for
something and i didn't yeah i'm an idiot
i didn't it didn't don't say i didn't
see it
here girl you're crazy
she made the shelves and all that and i
went i went i go
i go where is it
and she goes are you kidding me and she
was she was she
could see she kind of like was so
disappointed in me like she was so like
she worked so hard on it and she went
like this she went
but i'll show you clean the garage i
felt so bad while she cleaned well guys
well she put like
he's telling an
yeah i don't notice stuff like that man
yeah but how many times does it i mean
they should understand they should
understand that well i had a girlfriend
above me a huge banana tree
and put it in the corner and bought me a
new dog bed i remember this
alley and she was like she designed she
was an interior designer for calvin
klein
for all that so she knew her [ __ ] man
and she would i'd come home and
i'd have there'd be a big banana tree
and a new dog bed
i didn't notice man i just didn't
[ __ ] notice
and then i mean i'd noticed that but
even that you know what i mean
yeah but on the same time it's about
being thoughtful on the up from the
other side too it's like i said whatever
your love languages are
i was just getting ready to say that
like if you're like acts of service i'm
acts of service that's my first one i
like
so i remember my girl she picked me up
from the airport all right
but when she picked me up from the
airport when i was coming down the
escalator
she was waiting for me oh she had a cart
and two coffins bro oh
bro would have proposed right there yeah
yeah yeah like what i'm saying
but to her was like well it doesn't
matter i'm just getting but it's like it
that's it don't matter yeah because
that's your lovely from the airport yeah
we're done
oh don't worry nothing more
don't hit me with this [ __ ] you call
somebody to go oh hit call me when
you're
when you're there hey check it out i
know when i'm there
yeah i'm flying in at five yeah
yeah if it's delayed i'll let you know
but other than that five
be there at when i'm there look this is
what i always say like
when i when i was single you know i'm
doing like i'm thoughtful like that
like i'll pick you up from the airport
and check it out i'm not circling the
airport
waiting for your text i'm not at the
cell phone line
i'm at baggage clan
you're a real one all right and check it
out say that again that was sex
yeah say one more whoa whoa whoa baggage
check this out too you don't got to tell
me your flight's coming in early cause
i'm tracking your flight off
yeah that's why you're engaged man
right that's how you do it she goes oh
my god i'm here 30 minutes early don't
worry boo boo
being thoughtful is like people i think
we lose sight of
those love languages and the thoughts
we lose track of that thinking that oh i
gotta get the the big thing
or the whatever the thing is yeah
because even even one of the love
languages receiving gifts
and and we kind of want language i know
but we think that it's about
you know monetary you know book that
love language book yeah the five level
oh man i'm telling you you got to take
the love language test that's
interesting let's take a little break
from riffin with the man
eric griffin because draftking
sportsbook is not only my favorite
sports book but also america's top rated
sports book i love using draftkings
because it's easy to navigate
plenty of instructions for new bettors
and they have all the ways to get in
on the action my friends and family also
love draftking sportsbook
and i bet you guys will too and they
have a great offer draftking sportsbook
is putting you courtside with a chance
to turn one dollar
into 100 dollars in site credits
that's right pick any basketball team
there's only four left so you can pick
the phoenix suns
the clippers the bucks or the atlanta
hawks all right you bet one dollar if
that team wins you win 100
in sight credits don't forget draftking
sportsbook also offers great odds
on baseball hockey ufc you got a big
uh main event this weekend with the
heavyweights
uh gone and our boy volkov that's right
that's this saturday
you got tank fighting this saturday
there's all sorts of ways to get in on
the action
with draftking sportsbook draftkings is
safe secure reliable so you can deposit
and withdraw your funds at your
convenience
download the top rated draftking
sportsbook app now use promo code
fighter when you sign up turn one dollar
into 100
in free credits bet on any basketball
team of your choice that are in the
freaking still in the playoffs and if
they win their next game
you can claim 100 in free credits that's
promo code fighter
for limited time only at draftking
sports but must be 21 or older
new jersey indiana pennsylvania only new
customers only wagers paid out insight
credits restriction supply see
draftkings.com
sportsbook for details gambling problem
call 100 gambler or
indiana 109 with it tell you what man my
kids are talking trash me in spanish and
it ain't cool
and i tried learning from these other
language books and stuff like that and
audible
books and it's not working thank god for
babel the number one selling language
learning app
there's a fun easy way to learn a new
language whether you're traveling abroad
connecting deeper way with your family
me my kids talking smack all the time
and my wife behind my back
babbling teaches bite size language
lessons that you actually will use in
the real
world all right babel's 15-minute
lessons make it the perfect way to learn
a new language
on the go on the card driving to work
working out whatever you're doing you
got some time you got 15 minutes
how about you learn a new language son
babel designs their courses with
practical real world conversations
in mind things you get to use in
everyday life all right
uh their teacher method has been
scientifically proven to be effective
with babel you can choose from 14
different languages including spanish
french italian german
start your new language learning journey
today with babel right now when you
purchase a three-month babble
subscription
you get an additional three months free
that's six months for the price of three
whoa just go to babel.com use the promo
code fighter that's b-a-b-b-e-l.com code
fighter
for an extra three months free babble
language for life really you don't know
it check it out check it out it's not
about the the la
it's not about knowing what they are so
much as like when you answer those
questions leading up to it it really
says a lot about like
it'll be like when you come home do you
want to just not see anybody do you want
you know like all these little things
that lead up to like then it tells you
like it's acts of service
uh what are those touch uh words of
affirmations
example like for a gift like you could
just be like you could send your chick
10 starbucks card just to be like hey
get yourself a coffee on me today
just that act of receiving that thing
just that small
some makes people fill
no no i don't know what i mean is uh
maybe not maybe not just like
i've i i moved a girl into my house
because the way she took care of her dog
and herself like there was something
about she was always
in always in shape always like her dog
everything about the way she took care
of her
[ __ ] together she had her [ __ ] together
see i think that girl should be good for
her i respect that
service right i think it goes under that
action service because you're you're
because you're also pro
you want that for yourself yeah i can
rely on it yeah yeah
i mean i don't know i mean i just think
it's important to know
in a relationship what the other person
values
because because it's not about doing
equal [ __ ] you know it's not about like
i gotta do what you do because we like
to say that yeah yeah now what it's
about is like i'm gonna do what i do and
i'll put it here and you do what you do
that's equivalent here
and we're gonna balance out like this
because if you if you spend time going
like you know if you're like the
breadwinner like
you wouldn't do that you wouldn't go i
make all the money what do you do
it's like it's not whatever the other
person does is equivalent if they're
like taking care of your kids or if
they're like
you know working on whatever they're
working on you have to have the the
balance yeah
so do you have a date set for the
wedding no but i'm letting her
and her mother what ethnicity is she
she's jewish
right so it's the whole thing the whole
big thing you know
how was mayor you did a man last week
yeah how was it he's such a
i didn't realize he did it like that so
that was how his spirit yeah you just go
in his backyard in his garage
and he just he's sitting from the
computer you know he's like all right
ready
and he just does it i was like was obama
like that yeah
oh yeah but obama just come over and he
was just like he had to submit questions
to obama before he came though oh really
yeah yeah
oh of course the president's not just
gonna riff from the hip
and they had guys come a day early oh
week early and shut down the street a
week early secret services on top of the
other houses with
sniper games and [ __ ] don't [ __ ] around
you said the neighbors were cool
though but you better be [ __ ] yeah
whether that states in my garage oh
yeah what depends on the neighborhood
yeah true is it the black president
thank you
i remember when trump wrote he was
walking across the remember he was
walking with the secret service like he
was being a tough guy yeah
going to that thing was uh are you a
marin were you boys at the store or no
no not really man that's no one really
is that that was the thing
that was the funny thing about it we
were talking about cause i said to him
like you know it was like eight
i don't know how many years ago it was
but i was doing a special whatever and
we asked to get on the show and he said
no
you know so then like just you just wait
for the right time he walks up to me at
the store and goes hey man you should
probably be on the podcast
you know that's you wait for those
moments and it happens when it happens
yeah what's dope you know what i mean
yeah man's a godfather man he's been
doing i think he's been doing longer
than rogan
i was doing a stand-up with mark 20 uh
30 years ago
yeah 30. driving 3-0 yeah so what are
you guys he was already
at that time he was pretty well known
like you know he was already written up
i was like what are you guys moving to
austin you guys uh no
did you consider it only one guy that
went to austin has 300 million dollars
you know what i mean
yeah everyone else is like we're all
going to go with him you know
he's like yeah i'ma move to montana and
then those golden gates went yeah
i i thought we were all in austin you
you never thought about it right no
i don't know do you ever think about
leaving no not at all i'm from la this
is my town you know
you know when you realize like weather
may not be that big a deal but let me
tell you something it's a big deal when
you're i was in
albany new york and anywhere in new york
anywhere austin right now right now it
you tell me about oklahoma
it's so hot and humid so and when you
walk anywhere you got to take six
showers a day
yeah wait did you get used to 75 and dry
and breezy you just do
you don't realize yeah we have sprunger
here that's it spring and summer all day
long
and then it's hard to have a bad day
yeah it's just there's some towns that
people always talk about how great their
town is let me get an example like
chicago
just
yeah from like you know in a mid april
and then every other time it's like it's
too hot or it's too cold
i don't wanna i like the snow like this
it's january my face my face hurt yeah i
needed to face myself
in chicago i snow for like two days i've
never been there in the winter time i've
been there in the summer oh please have
a seat
if you go to if you go to new england if
you go to like massachusetts
walk around harvard or you walk around
you know chicago
your face you cannot go without covering
your your face will start to hurt your
household new york it's called this [ __ ]
and you want to trade
another town i would never move to is
never the stinks too i was just there
new york city
it's great but it's a lot it's a [ __ ]
lot
everybody's on the street everybody's in
your face it's a parade
is it wide open though is it buzzing out
there below 14th street is a [ __ ]
european party that's cool it's
everyone's wide open i was just there
a month or so ago what were we doing i
was doing this ray romano movie
and like we were walking around and i
was like this doesn't feel like there's
a pandemic going on oh really because
they were super locked down yeah i
walked by john gotti's
old ravenite club and you know on
mulberry that whole area it was pretty
wild and it's just so touristy but the
mob used to run that place in the 90s
it was always like people would be out
the italian mob still a thing yes
i'm sure it is it's just it's not like
they used to be he's on the payroll i
know right yeah
they don't kill you anymore really i
think it's harder to kill people because
of cameras everywhere
yeah it's hard to get away with in the
same way you don't see bigfoot anymore
yeah
back in the day they had they you know i
mean they would
kill you in a restaurant but now it's
different i mean they killed
solano at spark steakhouse right in the
middle of
yeah like you could never do that now
never
they just get away yeah
comics like chappelle he would make
everybody put their phones in a thing
yeah to go into the restaurant yeah you
can't have your phone in there
oh if i'm at some italian joint imagine
where you're farming
i'm out yeah use check please you still
see old school dudes there that are
italian oh they're
still hanging out heavy and yeah
something's going on you can tell by the
suits huh
i think that they they don't wear suits
a lot of times they just they don't no
not in the summer they're just wearing
like they're wearing that
they're wearing like a hawaiian shirt oh
they're just trying to shake you down
like what the [ __ ] this ain't the 90s
the [ __ ] out of here they got into
podcasting and they busted in a room
like yeah
you guys need some protection well
that's the other podcast
it's hard to shake down yeah how do you
shake down like i don't know the
pancreatitis like i'm a corporation i
gotta
well i mean the big shakedown is the
government isn't it though i mean like
if the new york state government is a
little if you feel like it's corrupt if
like you know come on
you know like obviously stuff is going
on i mean it would just be like if you
open
you own a store and then they come over
and be like well if you want to be in
this store
who are you going to tell yeah who are
you going to call yeah yeah ghostbusters
you're not going to call anybody
you'll call the cops yeah some dude is
telling me i have to pay him money okay
we'll check on it like what are they
gonna do
you know then you have to they're not
gonna be where you got to have a 24-hour
guard i mean i totally get why it's like
yeah you're gonna have to
you know they still control some like
the construction the unions and [ __ ]
that's where they're making their way
well yes parking lots too right yeah
parking yeah we still have all the
business trash
it's more subtle like with trash it'll
be like what happens is
if you have a restaurant and you want to
shop around for a better price to get
rid of your trash
every day they'll go get go ahead
go live call around and what happens is
you call every trash company
and they go i don't work that area
that's all cause it's all
it's all it's so that's how that's how
it is yeah so what happens
so you'll don't pay the prices what are
you gonna do with the traffic fishing
dock
yeah and then if you have if you have a
construction job it's changing now
my buddy just built a building but you
know it used to be that it was just
you were gonna pay a certain amount it
was part of
the deal part of your business if you
were in the in you know if you were in a
family
you were going to have to pay guys who
didn't work but came every friday and
picked up a check
just the way it was the the
you know they're not going to like beat
you up no
i'm going to film these kids in a
different way but they can wind up
things up for you a little bit yeah
they make it difficult but now it's now
it's different because now
like construction is open to different
bids and different like it's
it's just different man new york is
different dove just built a building a
20-story building from that
and it there you have any shakedown or
anything so so
yeah so i saw him that was a player now
with
real estate but what double says is when
you go to do
real estate new york and you want you
want financing for
a business what happens is you're not
you're never going to get money
unless you have what's called a debt
partner unless you have a guy who has a
relationship with a bank who's done it
before
so you have to be in bed with a guy who
has
roots and has done it that guy's already
been dealing with that stuff yeah he
it's all part of why you hire that guy
why that guy's your partner
and then you got to be careful and make
sure he doesn't screw you over you know
it was really he he he's got really good
instincts because he had this partner
and he goes to meet the guy he's working
on a deal for eight months he goes to
meet the guy and it's a dude and he gets
buzzed in twice buzzed in twice
and he goes why the [ __ ] do i have to go
through two locked
buzz doors to get to this guy who's a
real estate guy
yeah this means people are after this
[ __ ] and then he gets out there
and the guy won't make eye contact
with him guys like no you want to make
the deal we'll make the deal i mean you
know
it's better to do it and he goes i'm out
of here
i'm not doing it they're like no you're
crazy he's got a track record hire
private either guys half a gangster so
in new york when you do that you got to
know what the [ __ ] you're doing you got
to know who you're getting in bed with
yeah that's true well if you have to
walk through a pawn shop
yeah back yeah you know what i mean you
do walk it through
a lot of times you do and guess what the
deal will be made it just depends it's
all instinct
it's like my boy moved to austin he's
trying to buy this land
he's like oh you want to buy the land
this has been family owned for
200 years he's like i don't give a [ __ ]
you swung by the line like you can do
that
whatever you build on this we get 10
percent off get the [ __ ] out of here
like
okay go ahead somewhere else goes
another place try the same thing
well all it's like the main real estate
is owned by like six main families they
talk
so yeah they talk so here's another
place because hey i'm gonna buy this you
can do that
ten percent yeah it's just part of doing
business
what do you do that's the way it is my
buddy in italy said something when you
open the business
he goes the police are the mafia it's
like if you go if you want that
sidewalk fixed you're gonna you call a
guy
you're not going to call the co you're
not going to call the city you call a
guy who has this in that area in italy
it used to be in new york city when you
had a bar
no matter who you were you had a my
buddy jimmy's dad had bars
you had a jukebox a jukebox and you
didn't want a jukebox
i want to play my own music no and what
happens is there'd be a guy who'd come
in every week
and just open it up and take the money
off the map gets all that and my buddy
was like
hey dude this is my bar you know this is
my bar
so i don't want to do this anymore and
so the guy would go well it's our spot
so you got
and and my buddies that was a smart ass
my dad now
[ __ ] you now [ __ ] you now and no so what
happens
uh two gorillas show up two gorillas
show up four hours later and they go
like this they go
look we don't want you guys
getting a fire starting or the windows
broken we're trying to
we're here to protect that's why we are
here you know we want those little freak
scenarios
with a drink so they can protect you you
know you're like we don't want your kid
who goes to such a such school
miss second-degree teachers
they don't have
i mean if the window breaks a lot that
sucks
you gotta you gotta close your eyes
you're one of the guys with this
pandemic you just powered through it you
weren't
you know talking about leaving or oh no
why are chill complain well the good
thing is like
i you know i i always feel like whatever
job i get
is going to be the last job i ever have
so which has made me frugal
and you know i i got an investor and i
my money's in the bank and so
this happened and i was like you know
what am i going to do and then i was
like oh i'm all right
then i just started doing other little
things and then things
things worked out i started streaming
error griffin gaming
um yeah i see you on that twitch yeah
eric griffin gaming on twitch every day
did you shoot at the workaholics movie
yeah no they haven't done it yet i think
they're still writing it
damn or they or or maybe they made it
and i'm not in it
but i know that's not going to take it
out no i don't know that's not the case
because adam told me about it
you you'd stream playing games yeah i
started streaming and then i got like a
bunch of
opportunities because of it like i did a
show where i played games with t-pain
then i did this other show because
amazon owns twitch so they got tons of
money
so they have all these like uh they got
all these like little things that they
do and there's
this lucrative listen i do i did let me
just say this i made more money
gaming in the gaming world than i did at
stand-up the year before
you know what i mean there's major money
yeah there's a lot of money in twitch
leah probably trying to learn videos
i always play call of duty but i'll play
other but i mostly play call
of duty yeah i'm a fun funny guy playing
video games yeah i'm not terrible but
it's like that's not just when those
kids call them uh the
racial slur and he's like all right and
just lit them the [ __ ] up dude that
happens all the time dude
this thing they do i have this funny
video up right now on tick tock
uh that's uh air griffin gaming it's um
you kill someone and then they turn the
mics on for like three seconds
after you kill him after you kill him
and so this guy he says to me he goes
he goes i'm coming back for you camping
[ __ ] you know
then i said i didn't hear me but i was
like okay you know
i'll be waiting you know but that but
you get a lot of stuff man
you get you they say a lot of crazy [ __ ]
on the kill camps and a lot of
a lot of times it's racial i was like
just white kids being racist you know
what i mean
it's like youtube they're just trying to
let it out if america is racist
this is the time i could [ __ ] really
do it or sometimes the kids that's true
there's one there's one kid that's one
little kid
you could tell he was a little kid he
gets killed and you hear him say he goes
daddy stop touching me you know what i
mean but they're just trying to be funny
yeah you know what i mean they're just
trying to be like true because you can't
really trace it back to them
if they're not really known on the
platform right yeah this i don't even
post a lot of stuff and look i posted
this video of the of this thing and it's
like more
likes than i ever you know yeah would
you get would you
keep doing stand-up if i gave you 30
million dollars no you would not you
stop
i'm out i'm out i'm almost 50. i'm done
yeah
i think i want to deal with that [ __ ]
you don't like the road anymore people
no
i would do it like i was hanging out
with ray romano during this movie so
we're hanging out he's telling me about
he does stand up four times a year god
damn four and a quarter
four times a year okay he goes to the
mirage four times a year and that's it
that's how you want to do he's such a
vet like he's wait and he's telling me
like this too he goes he goes
he goes you know yeah we fly in on
thursday blah blah blah do the shows
like golf
ball and then sunday and night after the
show and he's being real
modest he goes you know we you know we
fly home on a private jet
you know i said right you earned it bro
oh yeah yeah
don't you don't don't feel bad that you
flying on a private jet yeah
i'm trying to get there like
you let me know that that's the end goal
but it's i'm like it's fine so
what i'm saying if you're getting 30
million dollars i'm trapped i'm going to
the the great wall of china i'm going to
[ __ ] get that going everywhere you
head to china
all kinds of stuff are you uh have you
been doing stand up around la have you
done spots yeah yeah i'm doing all these
little spots
yeah supernova i do the comedy store
comedy store's not the same
guys it's just not the same yet that
weird spacing and
you know i don't know i think that once
the place opens up
and i think the or in the main room are
probably like a little weird but the
belly room
been pretty dope yeah but i probably
still not the same it's not the same
it's not a hangout spot anymore it's
like that that hey day that
last five six years whatever that was
it'll be one of those things we look
back on
oh yeah you know be like oh wow i
realized that you didn't really i didn't
realize that at the time until it was
gone it was a renaissance
yes for sure for sure so yeah but i've
been doing a lot of shows i've done that
but
so you still do the podcast listen
you're not talking about you earned
money over time in your business doing
your business and then you
you still do that business you're
talking about you won the lottery
the lottery let's say the lottery's at
yeah 500 million
yeah they drop it you win it on
wednesday's lottery
buy you know yeah
it's not like because that's like one of
those things where here's a gift and you
go okay now let me reevaluate whatever
you just stopped doing everything though
i don't know maybe i'm just saying that
right now let me take a year off you
miss it bro
i think that's what you mentioned this
past year i i didn't stop yeah oh
see well there you go i i was forced i
was at home maybe if i stopped doing it
i would never come back
i have a weird love-hate relationship
with all the whole business that's what
i'm like
when you're on the road non-stop yeah
like if you go three weekends in a row
or four weeks in a row you're like
in that traveling like yeah traveling is
[ __ ] the worst
that's the worst but if i you know if
you could fly private no but here's what
i would do if you gave me all this money
i still want to do stand-up but then it
would be like
i would it would be one week in a month
it would be it would be the nice way i
would do it like chappelle's doing it
you know maybe i have i build a farm
someplace that's mine with a theater and
i'd private jet everybody in
all my friends and it'd be like a
festival every weekend yeah you know
something like that you know what i mean
all right take all this money and be
like hey let me buy the commie store
no matter what the cost tell me how much
you want for it you want 200 million
dollars here's 200 million dollars i'll
take it all
yeah and then it'll be like you know
then it's like this is the spot
you can go yeah yeah you know what i
mean so i mean i get that but it's like
this grind of the business
but i just went through this whole thing
man i booked the pilot we shot the pilot
it didn't get picked up
all the emotions i went through through
all that i'm like oh my god do i want to
go through this and
keep going through this i am going to
keep going through it but it's like
you're saying here's the alternative
here's 30 mil
but a lot of guys when they get super
famous like they're stand-up comedians
by trait and then they book a movie and
they blow the [ __ ] up they stop doing
stand up
oh that's like the old days man yeah but
it's also like you can kind of
understand it's like yeah they're
probably sick of the grind man yeah
i never get sick of writing and come up
with new ideas right that's what that's
the part
i don't give a [ __ ] about anything else
like what i really love is but that's
not the thing
i'm trying to right now and it's such a
[ __ ] i sit there and stare at a
wall but when i get a little
when i figure something out and surprise
myself i'm like that's that's what i
live for yeah
[ __ ] don't you have like that's just
an itch to like you we have these
thoughts and as an entertainer as a
performer as an artist because that's
what it is
you just you want to actually you want
to show that art you don't just yeah
paintings just to be like leave it in a
basement no
i don't want anyone to see this no i'm
not doing stan i'm not doing this yeah
my thing is different my thing i i want
to see what's in me like i i'm
i i don't know i'm always afraid i'm not
going to be as good as i could be like
that maybe that's what oh see i know
what keeps you going
yeah yeah yeah like i want to know what
i'm capable of i want i like to surprise
myself and i love when i write an hour
and it all seems to be thematic and i
didn't even know what was happening
and that's when you're not looking for
laughs either anymore yeah you're just
that's when you're
looking for a true connection yeah
they're laughing because they agree or
disagree with you and all that kind of
stuff and that's just
you know so yeah you're always going to
have the itch for that i mean i love
that i like challenging myself i like to
let me see what what is the most
outrageous thing i can say on stage
to make a point that most people
wouldn't be able to say
you know what i'm saying i try to do
that don't always succeed but i try to
do that
and that's you know you know you're
pretty damn good at it you know
well i'm you're obese i'm also into like
maybe i'm also into
just like when what it takes to get
really good like i want i go down these
[ __ ] gordon ryan john donahue
these rabbit holes it sounds weird maybe
your life jiu jitsu what i love about it
is it's such an art like those
[ __ ] take it like gordon ryan
doesn't even look like he's moving much
but
like when you watch john donahue talk
about technique like the details
it's mastery of something and i think
you learn a lot about life when you
master and does that inspire you
like in every standard yeah yeah but
there's anybody that's
like that there's this kid his name is
jay god
on on youtube and he's a gamer guy
his name is jay god you know and but he
is the biggest
video game nerd and what he does is he
breaks down
like every gun in the game and he does
these videos where if you play call of
duty you're like
i gotta go find out what jacob is into
he's so it's that kind of thing
it's the kind of like yeah yeah he's got
people like
you know he does these videos like top
10 loadouts to use and
and you go well what is this but it's
kind of like fantasy football yeah
the kind of guy that's like a stack
cruncher this is this guy he's a geek
for this game
those guys
yeah it's like that gaming world i met
with my merch company i'm like
who's your biggest guys i'm like where
am i at and they show me i'm like
that's not bad but then you see the top
dog and it's that ninja kid yeah ninja
nick marks and those guys
oh my god his name's ninja yeah why what
do you mean by top dog like
dude he makes about five hundred
thousand dollars a month more oh
[ __ ] i'm just i'm just saying the fact
that like so i don't care what
podcast we're talking about he signed a
deal with adidas
yeah dude it's just what the [ __ ] yeah
this guy's this guy's incredible
24 24 million subscribers yeah he's
[ __ ] amazing
you know i walk down like who the [ __ ]
merch is that
like oh ninja i'm like ninja who yeah
they're like the video games million
subscribers [ __ ]
24 points i gotta get into but jiu jitsu
and [ __ ] games
and yeah in his merch his merch
i mean rogan's got this funny video that
they're putting out about how he was
like saying video games are bad
you know like video games are bad for
you you should open a jujitsu thing
instead like you
practice jujitsu for three years and you
can open up a dojo and teach people
and i'm like yeah bro i made a lot of
money playing video games yeah
yeah but my friend he got back he just
does you know rogan's also
50 was he 54. dude he like you asked my
dad
yeah like my son was uh playing his
nintendo switch when i was like how do
you know i'm on that thing
that's just a waste of time like yeah
it's 21 dog like yeah
you know it's kind of the future a
million dollars yeah
that's why i tell them i know a lot of
guys make [ __ ] ton of money doing this
[ __ ] yeah i'm not saying i want that
for him but
it's tough when you're playing video
games like y'all give me a lose you do
all your life
i think if you're really good at
anything it's it's you know
you're going to find your way if you're
really good at something you can apply
it to something else
or you'll get you'll get rich well yeah
if you're yeah like i don't know but you
know those kind of guys that like you
know they
you know you they were like 19 and they
were like yeah yeah well i started a
vodka company or you know it's like that
kind of thing they they always have
these things that they're doing
eventually something's going to hit yeah
like there's those guys that are that
go-getter-type people yeah
yeah they're trying stuff and they're
like well i built my first car when i
was 15 years old and now i
do this or that and i like seeing that
it's like those youtubers when you know
they all have a big following they're
all making millions of dollars then they
get a house
it's like the youtube house where the
hype house whatever it's like
six or seven of them with their team
there dude i just went to one they're
all just you know they're all like
millionaires and they just create
content it's like
i mean that's their college yeah that is
their college
you know i'm tired man i wish i took my
true niogen i wish
i wish i took it this morning i was
working at zoo sometimes you feel
drained
but not anymore i love true nitrogen
true nigerian fuels the body's energy
engines
maintains cellular metabolism and even
supports heart health
i have more energy than ever before can
you tell i wish i took an idea that's
why i
sound tired they have 11 published human
clinical studies backed by nobel prize
winners
true nigerian a supplement that
clinically proven to boost
nad levels an essential coenzyme
required for cellular energy and repair
since taking true nitrogen it helps my
muscles recover after these beasty
workouts all right
i just have more zest for life all right
and with true nitrogen you guys new
customers can save 10 for your first
purchase by going to truenigen.com
fighter use code fighter that's true
nigerian t-r-u-n-i-a-g-e-n.com
fighter code fighter to save 10 percent
off your first per ship
first purchase truenigen.com fighter
code fighter
these statements have not been available
by the food and drug administration this
product is not intended to diagnose
treat or cure prevent any disease
truenigent.com fighter hey dude
i was just at one of these things
because i'm about to be a part of
another podcast with this
influencer kid i'm not going to say
because i think he wants to do a whole
thing whatever so but
whatever i went to this it was a it was
what is it called a
stream house or not what's they had a
name for yeah there's something
like a cam girl house but for our gamers
or like just for like take tacos they
got those
i think it's called hype house what
we're doing uh we're doing a photo which
is one particular specific one that's
like a brand name
there's hype house there's trap house no
no this is there it's not like
a trap house no no this was like they
had a name for it and it was like
there was a computer set up you know
there was computers set up for editing
there's green screen over here but it
was a beautiful house and like what did
you say cat
is the phase clan they're really faced
no no no
no but i'm just saying it's like i i
when i saw this i was like oh i
appreciate this so like you know when
people go like oh these tick tock stars
these kind of i go
they don't really know the extent of
work
that some of these kids are putting into
it though they're constantly
like okay i gotta film something you
know they're constantly they're taping
and taping and typing and editing and
editing
it's a job and it should be do you see
logan paul's house there's like
cassettes in his garage
yeah heading bay yeah there's merch on
this room and it's like you go in there
like oh [ __ ] this there's people coming
in and now he's got a bus outside
correct he has a button yeah i did this
podcast and i was like
you know what's funny about that i did
like so five years before
he made this movie terrible movie okay
but he was it was it was it was garbanzo
right i don't know what he said
the way he emphasized that
all right whatever but he was into it
because they wanted to
they they wanted that like validation of
hollywood
back then so all those influencers like
a lot of them they would hit me up and
be like can you be in one of my videos
because it was like oh i'm workaholics
guys
you know it's now they don't care about
hollywood
they don't give a [ __ ] they're not
trying to make movies hollywood's not
[ __ ] with them right but hollywood
has
no clue they don't even know how they
keep trying no lane
let's put an influencer in a movie and
the people that are there
for like a minute yeah yeah it doesn't
work like that but also also they're
just trying to get in on the money and i
love that these kids are like [ __ ] you
yeah they're doing their own thing
they'll do their own thing that's like
you know one of my friends you know
amanda cerny i love amanda she's like
she's been on my podcast too and she's
like
she's got like 25 million followers
whatever and she's like monetizing to
the
extent she makes funny videos all the
time she ain't worried about being on tv
and all this kind of stuff
only fans all this kind of stuff she's
like look at my
the six two of my houses i got a house
in miami i got
it's like they figured out like this is
a different branch of entertainment
and it's like good for you yeah and
there's a lot of times they're they're
making content
last 15 seconds just quick quick
interesting
i know but the thing is they got to keep
going yeah man you guys don't know
amanda gorgeous yeah
she's an episode of workaholics okay
jesus christ she's
[ __ ] gorgeous and she's and she's
into fitness and health and that's her
whole brand she's a multi-millionaire
yeah man
i've seen her videos with joe coy yeah
she don't mess around and what i'm
saying is this is the new thing like
this is like a a a entrepreneur
beautiful ass woman monetizing all of it
making it happen monetizing all of this
you know what i mean that's bradley
she's everywhere all over the place and
she's got a great fitness brand and all
this kind of stuff kudos to her and
doing her damn thing when i'm doing her
damn thing so what i'm saying is like so
a lot of these kids
out here we're from this old school old
head type of like
this is how hollywood's supposed to work
and these people are like no no no this
is how we're doing it now
yeah like i've said this before man
instagram remember how we used to clown
girls who call themselves instagram
models
now they're the only models correct
that's right yep you know
right wow i didn't even think about it
you know you see some random chicks you
got 24 million followers i don't even
know who this
is but bang drink does yeah yeah yeah
yeah her bank account does it
yeah adidas know who the [ __ ] she is oh
yeah so i'm just like i go
we just have to we just have to change
our mentality of like what i think you
got to do in comedy too
but that's what this is that's what this
is but also like
especially this is your only fans kind
of okay but i'm not gonna show my feet
but also
when you look at like yeah but you're
always working out this is the same [ __ ]
same [ __ ] but like when you look at the
old school model of like an hour
everyone every week we all know you
shoot is an hour an hour hour
you talk to netflix.com central like we
know for a fact people stop watching
after 28 minutes yeah
we still do and not only that and we
know they only a lot of them only watch
the first
six months and then you don't have clips
but not only that not only that
what you're supposed to do now whatever
you think your best jokes are put at the
top
they get you start your special with
that you don't save it for your clothes
anybody you talk to will tell you oh
they all say the same thing so amazing
put your clothes at the top
because they're not they're not going to
make it make the person but you make the
personal stuff later yeah they might
stick around
and you're still thinking about
thematically yeah yeah yeah like you
know how you set it all up like an hour
like what the [ __ ] are we doing i was
doing cigarettes two beers one cave and
i was telling like
i don't get it man why i don't get why
the industry doesn't adapt
you can i've sat in front of netflix
these people they go after 28 minutes
they stop watching it's like
then why would i why not race this other
30 minutes
once you guys do 30 minutes specials
then which they're doing a lot more
they're going to do that now they're
going to be where they are or whatever
you want to do
do 20 minutes set with 10 minutes of fun
[ __ ] but also didn't shane gillis do
doesn't he have a uh it's a uh
sketch show on his youtube yeah it's
like a high quality sketch high quality
sketch show he
posts the clips on his own snl said [ __ ]
off and he was like oh okay i'll do yeah
that's hilarious
technology's at the point now where you
know look at this like eight camera
setup you got right here with the fancy
mics and i mean
technology's at a point now where if you
put some money and effort into it
you can make whatever you want to make
and then you're looking for an audience
the audience is there it's on youtube
the internet has made it so like here's
the audience you know and they also like
it that you don't like if you
if we were with say i don't know some
big network like spotify or something
like that
the fans that came with us on this
journey when you do make that jump like
uh it's
we're out man we liked it when it was
their [ __ ] whenever once you
sign like you almost cash out the girl
we're out man what are you saying about
rogan man what are you saying
his audience is older his audience is
older he's gonna ride
wide oh yeah
60 million now she's over at spotify and
i
my girl watches her thing and so like
you know i don't get to watch anything
on my tv anymore so
we're watching her youtube videos and
it's just she actually just it's not her
phone
but it's like she's using her phone and
she just does a vlog where all the time
she's like hey everybody
i met my buddy brian hey man you know
yeah yeah and she's
and it's just huge she's huge what is
she i don't i don't give a [ __ ] with
that sexual like you know
everything man it's like it's like what
i said i think that hook it up with guys
i think that women
it like that get into podcasting man
because
you have even like there's an extra
layer
if you're hot like that chick and you're
smart
entrepreneur and entertaining got some
shits and [ __ ] that's admitted dude it's
like
she produces and edits that [ __ ] that's
what i'm saying and not only that you're
talking about the
the the different types of ads like when
you look at the
metrics of your podcast i bet you it's
like 90 dudes 10 percent women i mean
that's just how it is ours yeah
if you can get if you could get that
female market because the the marketing
revenue
for because look at tv man if you if
you're during the day you're watching tv
it's all the commercials are for women
you know
all the commercials over women oh yeah
all whatever that stuff is there's a
market for those people to watch and
listen to podcasts too so
there's like this feeling that like
podcasts are all about guys but it's not
it's like uh uh what's that other one
the two girls that were um
uh guys i [ __ ] yep they're huge
they're comics also the biggest podcast
too is those uh
uh crime like uh cereal yeah yeah yeah
yeah
the comedy and the the rogan pockets
aren't the biggest the biggest are like
those crime docu series
like the those series how they do it or
the women's podcast
those are [ __ ] huge yeah rogan's
become a place for news like where you
can get
news you can trust almost because you're
he's interviewing scientists and people
who are
like who are those two people well not
according to fouchy
yeah voucher begs today he just had
and they're great because that i'll
listen to them that that sounds like i
started listening they just complain a
lot
how they do it's just like [ __ ] dude
isn't that what podcasting is
i mean we really don't but they just
complain about everything i'm like [ __ ]
dude i know i
yeah so they both have their thing yeah
it's crystal
and uh it's about bigger and they're
great
they left the hill to do that no i
listened to the whole show and then i
started listening to their podcast it's
good they just complain a lot about both
sides though
you know like we're not like yeah but i
want solutions too though i don't want
just complaining
well if you're looking for solutions
from those two you're already in trouble
well you saw rogan went off on that one
cnn show because the guy was like you
know
people were just watching youtube and
he's making he made a valid point
because your
show sucks like it's like this kind of
the entitlement of news these news
networks the entitlement they
feel that ratings well we are the ones
you're supposed to get news from and
we're just kind of like [ __ ] 2021.
i don't watch cnn because i already know
how they feel like i'm not going to get
new i don't feel like
i know the agenda i'm not getting news
i'm getting your opinion
yeah that [ __ ] guy whatever his name
is i don't give a [ __ ] about that guy
brian seth
setzer or whatever the [ __ ] is like i
don't care about you dude i have nothing
in common with you and you give me your
opinion
you went from a college right to a
newsroom probably like most of those
people in new york times new york post
they go right from college a really
expensive college
right to the newsroom you don't have any
experience you just have your ideology
and i can finish your sentences
yeah yeah [ __ ] guy ryan
i don't like is he off the air now or is
he no he's still on but he's a [ __ ]
donut
and i can tell you what he's going to
say all this i wonder how many
the reason why i asked about this the
reason why i asked about like his
following
because check this out this is my point
so he's on a network where
a major network where they're supposed
to listen to what he's saying
yeah and people don't give a [ __ ] what
he's saying i don't care about him you
know what i mean no one gives a song
it's like critics man he's also a mystic
just like critics he's a mouthpiece for
he he's he does what he's told in a lot
of ways i know but what i'm saying is
like if nobody's interested in him
why would anybody be interested in his
show now because it's a correlation now
but also how much does he really give a
[ __ ] yeah they literally
the cnn goes after fox news it's so
funny well they go after each other yeah
that's all it is
so all these networks going through or
what are you here to shoot about
apparently he's been you know leaking
information because i think he
look the guy but he's crushing it like
yeah his ratings crash
you know what if i was making 60 70
million dollars a year to talk [ __ ]
about
whatever yeah that i mean then you start
to see the brilliance of it
sure
that's the question well then no no you
know on fox though the actual
news i got some podcasts you know they
have new they have a news but we just
don't know about that
i'm saying all the other [ __ ] if you're
watching hannity or tucker like that's
not
right that's right that's another thing
it looks the same it shouldn't look like
i know that's my breaking news at the
bottom yeah it shouldn't look the same
so when you watch the news
you see guys sitting at a desk going
like today and then you see tucker
carson and sean hannity and they're
doing the same thing that you go
okay well which one is the one there's a
completely different segment yeah i'm
just saying that now it's like you know
you don't you're not holding them
ratings you're just
good guys it's the reason why when i see
someone like tucker carlson and he made
like
i don't know what look at his sports he
probably made like 65 million
or some [ __ ] like that i go yeah then i
get it then you are being influenced by
you know that's a lot of money man like
can you can you like that's a lot of
freaking money
like how can you not you know you just
got a [ __ ] word like his salary is
six million dollars his net worth is 30
million dollars a lot of money it's a
lot of money
so some of your bosses say if whoever if
ted what's his name that
owns uh what's his name ted uh what's
his name
that owns the fox is like yeah you know
i kind of like trump
yeah you know then you're ted ted um
what the [ __ ] man come on he goes hard
in the paint for fox
ted what the [ __ ] is his name come on um
why rupert
james rupert not ted i'm thinking about
ted
ted turner that's what we're thinking of
anyway my point is so
but we have to have like remember that
the the supreme court justice uh
that trump appointed oh um
i like what she said she said like she
was like you're really questioning my
integrity
right yep like you really think that
it's like it's like i'm like she's
worked her whole life to be a judge and
you're and then and that's what we do
though
when it comes to money when it comes to
like political science and politics we
go
where you must be influenced by and it's
it's a shame that that
go out yeah it's a shame that we think
that first but i've not went through
some
[ __ ] to get that position she did boy
they lit his ass
up what is her name i said supreme court
what yeah yeah yeah the supreme court
justice
no no no no no no no no no no she's
she's blonde right there she is
amy and she's actually done a lot of
great uh you know stuff like a
bipartisan like it's like i would like
to think that she raised
she adopted a bunch of children too i'm
just saying if you make it to this the
highest court in the land
i gotta think that it's not a movie
where it's like you're like this like
evil stepmother who's like let me do
whatever the one side thinks you have an
impeccable record you have an impeccable
record right
[ __ ] yes you know what i mean and you're
smart regardless of whether you're
liberal or conservative you're smart
you know you know what the [ __ ] you're i
don't know i mean i guess who knows man
you know who knows i mean some people
would say that a few of these justices
have this sort of like but even even uh
ginsburg when obama said yo why don't
you retire because you about to die all
[ __ ]
you know basically basically it was like
we had a cancer and that's why the last
she went like this she was she's like
read it now so that they can convert
somebody and she was like i'm going to
stick it out well you're going to die
you got
you got to leave [ __ ] you're going to
die when some you know
say no republican is going to be an
offer right and that's what she said
she said i don't know i was like good
for her
yeah but the liberals were like dude
come on that's
all right jim what do you got
already
okay so next month jeff bezos and his
brother are planning on
doing a space trip where they travel out
of the earth's
atmosphere or our gravitational pull a
lot of people
then went online started several
petitions trying to make it
so he doesn't come back talk about a
waste of time yeah
i mean why wasted people like well you
know
so is jeff like okay i'm not coming back
you know what this is this is
like haters when you're married or in a
relationship and you want to buy a
certain thing and your girl keeps going
no
yeah that's stupid yeah now he's like
yeah i'm not a space [ __ ]
i think it's i think it's because he's
bored i mean you're going to [ __ ]
space
there's nothing else right that's an
example of where you're like
what else can i do yes so much what i
mean what else can you do it's also
pretty swimming with whales
what would you do with money swim with
whales i'd have a pet
great white yeah whatever you want it's
super risky after a while you're like
going to space well that that thing
hasn't come down a couple of times you
know yeah it's super risky it's not a
good idea
oh never [ __ ] no but also those people
have signed the penetration they should
just take them like
no one has anything going on right now i
mean so you sign that thing
are they still buying from amazon though
yeah oh yeah yeah by the way
the funny thing is if the petition's on
amazon
yes he made a product that all of us use
like all of us everybody
everybody so it's like not his fault the
way it's like i know you made
hey josh we all [ __ ] use this product
he was a bad dad cool
i can't live without my [ __ ] awesome
swipe device
[ __ ] off so
in florida man news uh there was a
gentleman who ordered coffee along with
a bagel he did not receive
cream cheese with his order he was very
frustrated
he came he came back after leaving that
starbucks with a he came back with a gun
and then pulled it on the girl
complaining that she forgot his cream
cheese she then gave him the cream
cheese
for sure a few hours later he was
arrested because that girl's father
happens to be the police chief of that
area that's the only
people that get justice in florida
apparently that's what the story made
her sound like i can't get cream cheese
again though
wow
never mess up order again yeah but but
again this is like
another nuanced story because obviously
there's something up with this guy yeah
he has actually clearly
like like we'd like to think that we're
screaming the story's presented like
he's just a normal guy
and then he did this thing he's
obviously yeah
obviously you know what we've all
thought about this
yeah yeah where you just get today how
many times i've wanted to like run
somebody over who's taking too long in
the crosswalk
like [ __ ] it's like especially if i
stop for you yeah
i'm just saying there's so many times
when you've just been like i've been in
a restaurant and been like yeah don't
put any pickles
and no mayo on this then you open up the
burger and there's mayo
there's a moment i want to [ __ ] stab
this [ __ ] in the throat
it should be okay like we should get one
a year like the purge like
we should get one a year it's like
russell uh crow and on hinge
oh yeah yeah yeah we all think it's like
we don't
we think things but we don't follow
through with don't act
like that dude who came into that police
precinct with a machete and just
everybody's like working and stuff and
you see this guy come around the corner
and just goes and just [ __ ] hits this
dude but apparently he hit him like with
the flat end like try to but missed like
with the end piece
dude runs another guy's wrestling with
him and then finally somebody shot him
in the arm and he [ __ ]
you know he must not have been black he
was oh he got shot in my arm no way
i think no way a black dude a machete he
gets shot i don't know if he was blind i
think he was it looked like
the video the video is a little grainy
but uh
all right little grainy video excellent
so yesterday
the foo fighters brought on dave
chappelle at madison square garden to
perform creep
oh my god i saw that yeah
[Applause]
wow he's really feeling himself now huh
yeah if i was as famous as dave
chappelle i don't know if i'd be like
dave or if i'd be like daniel tosh
like dan tosh doesn't do he kind of just
hides yeah
no interviews no podcast about it he's
just kind of like i haven't had all this
money my whole life like you know
tash you know just about he's like i
just got all this money
you know what i mean so it's like i feel
famous for a long [ __ ] time yeah but
he hasn't been 20 million dollars a
special famous
true true he's been pretty well we've
been milling it for a hot second
not this strong of a he's flying people
private every week
yeah he owns a city
it's not terrible no because that's not
a really good it's a fun version
yeah what a great song it really is
want to get to the chorus no no you've
seen it
you know what's funny you say that
everybody everybody sung that song you
know you say it's a great i
um i started to think like i'm a big
american idol fan
you know i love american idol right did
you do you vote for uh
what a travesty that the white guy with
the guitar
won a singing competition no no shade on
him
with the big gaster one dude her or
willie
how many times i cried when willy was
singing it was the same [ __ ] over and
over
here here we go how do i sell albums for
willy what are you gonna do this is dude
check this out who's willing he's not
ruben stutter willie
willis big big black he's a big fat
black dude yeah yeah i see him he's like
just like every white guy with a guitar
is the same gospel no no
when he starts willie's son okay
coldplay was on all right
and it was coldplay week and he sung
yellow
and i was like damn that's a great song
and what it made me realize is that's
really where the art is like how you
just said creep is a great song yeah
like some of those guys are
like they're not they got it the least
single creep he ain't [ __ ] frank
sinatra
you know but he they made some great
songs
and that's really the art that's the art
so you take somebody like like
who has a great voice he's american idol
artists they come on with their great
voice and they're singing other people's
songs
and then they make their own songs and
you're kind of like uh like what's going
on because the completion the completion
of it
is that's the real art right there very
few people can write the instrument the
instrument is great
but were you voting for willian [ __ ]
every week no i've never voted i never
vote because i
could like dvr i don't watch this guy
chase chase
beckham yeah he won over the country he
won over
the the two most phenomenal singers that
have been on america how about that
white girl's
ass i was like just so distracted and
the way she was shaped too she was
shaped like [ __ ]
she was like yeah she was like skinny
face small waist
they did like she had a little baggage
bro
make her dresses like her [ __ ] jeans
were not for her
she's gonna be a star though they're all
gonna be stars and like i say
kudos to chase who won but it's like to
me it's a singing competition and
he did not sing as well as those other
two is what i thought but he's probably
a better artist oh boy
but the country's popping she's very oh
okay yeah they wanted a star
pretty face small face with a big bang
those are
she's 20. okay that's that's it yeah all
right yeah and what
what was her style of saying she's
saying that like good copy just no
just uh just you pick a song she could
sing it yeah
she should have won i thought
[Applause]
she could sing rock she was singing she
was like
dc yeah how old is casey bishop like
16. no i thought she was 14. no she's
16. she goes oh you had to be a
certain age she was she's no no they
made it like you know that all they care
about is this 12 and up
she was a beast though jesus some of
these kids she killed oh dude
she's the most talented yeah she's
almost done i thought too much
you know why because you know what you
know what he was talking about with
willie he's really saying is really
don't look like an american idol will
you keep big
his little t-rex arm and then like his
neck that's right i just thought it was
just
like this i felt for him because i was
like yo dude you have his instrument is
so
powerful and i'm like dude make sure you
because he already was sick his mom had
a stroke
healthy and i'm like you know i want him
to i want to i want him to survive
because he's such a great singer like
i'm telling you oh simpson i mean this
is uh he you've played us that rihanna
song
yeah oh he can really shine bright like
a diamond but anyway my point though is
that
you know i when i heard him sing you
hear him sing
established songs you start to go wow
you really
realize like oh what a great great song
and that's where the artistry is too not
just about the instrument
itself you know what i mean yes so you
don't think willie's marketable it's
like a good joke with a bad performer
he's not selling that's right that's
always so frustrating it's really
frustrating
great joke writers yeah sometimes you
have really great joke riders but you
know what though those guys going to
write for her no no but check it out
though they're really great joke writers
sometimes
maybe they're not like phenomenal
performers they still are the most
successful well i mean look
it's like a marathon not a race is such
a good writer that jasmine can stand
there
still he sees a good performer actually
he's a good performer he's totally
bad but but but anthony can just kind of
speak
those jokes and crush i said like
seinfeld's like that when he was first
coming up
like he's a really good he's a wordsmith
but he had a thing you know yeah
i know but it's not like smith martin
lawrence no
you know what i mean you know it's not
murphy or eddie murphy or like you know
like i'm talking about these dynamic
like performers they're on stage you
just go wow this guy's like superstars
something about this kevin hart yeah
kevin hart is it's like it's not even
riding with him so much it's just the
other performing the performing
arts and when you when he hits in a
pocket of a premise that you go oh [ __ ]
you combined with that
yeah so i'm saying singing is the same
kind of thing man it's the same thing
a lot of people got [ __ ] music i went to
spotify listen to willy's
you know uh original tracks and i was
like you ain't gonna make it with this
[ __ ]
that country guy had a oh you know who i
like the kid he got in trouble because
he like just
don't even get me start no you know how
you went to mullet and the hat i loved
him
i resent the fact that they canceled
this kid who who
when he was 12 his friend like he's
supposed to be online
and he did like 12 years old like he's
supposed to be responsible for the
years old and you want to talk he was
the most original i think he's going to
make it he wrote all of you
disgusting though
no he just i think they took him off i
think i think it was a mutual it was
like yeah i don't think we could survive
this let's just walk
he's 12 years old you [ __ ] was 16
[ __ ] 12 at the time
so he was the kid then that one kid the
guy he was like the white boy from utah
he just left he just dipped i think he
was like i could probably make more
money just doing this myself
you guys gonna vote me off if you
thought if he would have won i would
have been fine me too
he was like the most original he was
original i follow him
i sent him a dm i slid into the dm's
like
you good man keep it up respond no
but i don't care i just was like good
for you man i gotta you know i i
that's my favorite thing about the
internet my absolute favorite thing is
like
whoever your favorite whatever is you
can hit them you have the
opportunity for them to see your love
yeah like i listen to a lot of
audiobooks
and if i like the reader i'll find this
[ __ ] on twitter and be like
yo that's you perform the [ __ ] out of
that i really love your reading and i've
listened to other books just because
you're reading them
and they go oh my god thank you i mean
you know that's when it's like no one's
giving them a lot because yeah no one's
giving them that kind of love
you know what i mean or like even
authors or like you know any kind of
thing you anybody you find people you
just go i really appreciate what you
just want to deliver
that's what the the the point of it was
not like the constant hate you know
like i'm gonna i get like man the the
most hate i get is after doing this
podcast and there's
gonna be so many of these [ __ ] trolly
ass like all you do is complain griffin
yeah it's my brand that's my [ __ ]
brand
but it's all well thought out someday
like it's not like you're just
shooting from the [ __ ] i know but you
know the point is it's like you have the
good and bad of the internet if
everybody loves you you're doing
something wrong
right true true for sure for sure for
sure
next one oh we still doing this so this
time last year the world's most
premature baby was born and it was given
zero percent chance of survival because
it was less than a pound and was small
enough to fit in
a palm oh yeah the baby turned one the
other day i bet you
i bet you this woman is so let's push
this little
thing out now instead of waiting for
five zero percent chance
look at that and is he is he normal like
brain everything works uh
i think for the most part he's as
healthy as you could possibly
have him one day but there are certain
uh little things that he has
well technically technology today man
like that baby probably wouldn't have
survived
even yeah just 20 years ago right now
just the fact that he's alive he just
turned one
he's amazing that's cool well that's the
the biggest debate about abortion is
that
after the baby is viable you you can't
really abort the child right that would
be the idea so that would be the cutoff
point
when it's viable on its own well maybe
they'll have the thing now we can just
take it out
into the oven and then
outside the woman's body now what does
that mean so yeah
i mean like well the baby's two weeks
older you know it's tricky it's [ __ ]
tricky
i don't want to get into it like an easy
date that's one of those that's one but
it's become a thing
like this i don't get it everybody's
checking out can you please put right
here the views expressed by brian
it's an issue it's an issue we're all
going to deal with though it's going to
come up it's like you know with
technology it's going to change
everything the way we think about
everything
well technology should change like i i
think you know we have to come up with
better forms of
birth control or all that [ __ ] whatever
it is like you know or like have it
where
like we have to have like i mean we're
just designed so terribly
and that's what i always say i feel for
women because it's like
you know if you're a woman you're 30 and
you want to have kids
well this has to be your thing you have
to think about because the older you get
the harder it is to have
so it's like but how great would it be
if it was designed differently that
that's how that a woman can have kids at
60 and it'd be fine that's right
yeah but i know i know but like she got
money
it was like a lot of true i mean we
don't know we don't know what was going
on
it might be celebrities are bad examples
yeah never mind just kidding
nah but they they're having technology
wherever what i'm saying is
all the time i know i know you haven't
but the technology there but what i'm
saying is like
it sucks that like that has to be the
pressure because you could be like
75 year old man and like you know yeah
and then pump out a baby
yeah you know that's all you have to do
you're an old [ __ ] i already feel
like if i
i'm my girlfriend yeah my kids then i'm
like i'm gonna be
50 in march so my [ __ ] is it's that's
not
okay let's be honest no you're good i
want my no here's the thing though
that's why i started to i really have
been consciously being like i got to
take care of myself correct that's right
because
my mom has dementia you know and it's a
tough uh
thing yeah and so then i thought oh man
is this heretic is it genetic
it's iffy if it's genetic or not and
it's like but but you know the causes
it's like
um high cholesterol inflammation take
care of yourself these things are so
huge and so i was like oh look at myself
as you get older it comes becomes harder
and harder and harder and harder to stay
in shape to you know
you have to watch what you eat you got
all this [ __ ] and i thought well i
have to do this because i want to be
here for my girl who's like
in her 30s and and if we have kids and
that you know i want to be like you know
i want i want to like walk my daughter
down the aisle with all these kind of
things you think about right so it's
like
that's why my message out to you young
men out there this is a real
solid message to you if you're a person
that thinks you want to be a dad if
you're thinking about
that as your future think about it
like really if you're with somebody that
you care about you need to really
consider like
do i want to be an old dad do i want to
be like you know
do i want to be 50 and my daughter's 20
do you want it to be like that
because i have all my high school
buddies who are like oh they show me you
know they're like oh my my daughter just
graduated college
yeah you're like yeah i'm like [ __ ] like
and so it's gonna be tiring it's gonna
be
so it is something to think about i know
you think you're invincible in
the world i started late man my son's
nine i got a
long wait i know but the thing is is
because when you're that's the thing
that's the struggle of an
artist either side male or female yeah
because like even women who are like
this is my career i want to do my thing
i'm freaking taylor swift or whoever you
are
and you're like doing doing doing maybe
you haven't made time to be like well do
i want to be a mom
and then same thing with me tough it's
tough it's a tough one
and then it's like and then it's not
just about like well i'm just going to
have a baby because there's people like
that you know i think pro actually
do that it just pumps seeds into like
you know you know like i want to have a
kid
i know people like that i might i have a
really close family friend she she got
pregnant from this rich guy
and and you could tell that's his thing
he just wanted to have a kid and he's
like he's got enough money to be like ah
you know
we're not getting married but i'll take
care of you you know what i mean and
then i can check in and out with my kid
i mean there's people like that
but for most of us we want to have a
loving a family we want to be in this
thing so i'm just telling you young guys
out there a lot of guys listening to
this podcast it's a lot of men
think about it look at the woman you're
with right now and decide like is this
my is this my
ride ryder dive [ __ ] is this the one
for me
and do i want to start a family go to my
website immortal.com
yeah whatever that means good you good
i'm good or is that it
well there's a couple more but if you
guys are good you're good
all right i was kind of acting climactic
my girl
by the way my girl loves your sweater i
told you that last time but she wears it
all the time awesome that's sweet that
pink
you know yeah the guard broke one
perfect always always full of awesome
knowledge
yeah eric griffin.com yeah are you on
the road anytime soon yeah
actually i got yeah if you go to my site
i got the i got some stuff i'm gonna be
in uh the comedy zone in jacksonville
actually
oh i know i already know but anyway and
then i'm these are some places i'm going
to be so i got some stuff coming up
i'm not i'm not big time like shop or
i'm going to be at like the such and
such convention center with
that boston's great what's the what's
the den theater
it's in chicago oh word i gotta fix that
the video is definitely house comedy
yeah
in the house of comedy they got their
things opening up and i'll be in tampa
so you know i'm there
you know and i put the tickets to those
places that i'm at a lot anyway too like
you can get the
comedy store or laugh back you're going
to edmonton in january
yeah i went there in november that [ __ ]
was cold in my mind i love edmonton
that's a good
good crowd that's good it's good yeah
but that's yeah what is it
airgriffin.com yeah
um only thing i coming up la
is july 16th through 17th l.a shop and
friends
where is that that is that ha has ice
house run haha
oh good yes i'm gonna do a full weekend
there in july wait the ice house
yeah well their management's helped book
in haas
they're doing construction they couldn't
get permits to the pandemic so now they
get the permit so now they're building
so be done what are they building
they're redoing the whole thing
wow the bus family owns it now oh no now
it's gonna be all corporate
uh i don't know still the same squad
that runs it
all right uh this keeps going down chin
we just had san jose
north carolina august 19th the improv in
san jose uh yep san jose and probably
yeah that's good
yep and then we'll have on there uh
las vegas august 12th through the 14th
that's at this the opening uh weekend
for um cap not cap cities what the
[ __ ] uh uh
wise guys vegas oh sure why always
opening
grand opening where's it at i don't know
i love it love it
you don't know yet but it's not like is
it gonna be on the strip or it's gonna
be downtown
it's downtown not on the script yeah
yeah yeah yeah take it out of [ __ ] going
tkkz.com and the new merch drops friday
thickboy.com
i think with three c's check out i'll be
at uh we're almost sold out uh helium
thick and delicious weekend uh friday
saturday i had to cancel the sunday show
but we're gonna do three shows on
saturday i think
and tickets are almost sold out
philadelphia pa
helium see you this friday and saturday
uh
uh roughhouse friday um coming up july
9th if you like to bet on combat sports
i'm going to try to interview some very
very smart people
give you guys good odds as usual uh
conspiracy social club is on
rockfin.com conspiracy social club
um and i'm having so much fun with that
and we're gonna be exclusively on
rockfence starting in july
big and hungry podcast as well july 15th
through the 17th baltimore maryland
magooby's joke house and then later on
following month august 26th brea improv
oh yeah boom mcgoobies
i have i have
[Applause]
they also they also owned san antonio
the lol same people yeah really yeah
all right eric we love you thanks bro